le ciel leur est tombé sur la tête
al'annonce de cette épidémie
depuis les habitudes de ce curé etc
sacristain se sont modifiées les
conduisant à faire de nouvelles
expériences
aujourd'hui ils vivent leur foi en
solitaire le dit moi je m'en méfie des
leçons là c'est la fête
si la joie mais je pense à eux
chaque jour chaque fois qu'on s'il aime
je pense aille dans leurs prières le
souhait de voir les églises se remplir
et revivre à partir du 11 mai à
condition de respecter les consignes de
sécurité
l'objectif pour nous c'est pas de
remplir l'église
mais ces deux studios comme l'avait fait
au tout début bien d'espacer les gens
dans les bancs si le faux bond on a
aussi dans certaines paroisses mis une
messe en plus de manière à dégrossir
l'assemblée et que les gens ne soient
pas les uns sur les autres c'est dans ce
sens là pour la communauté chrétienne il
n'y a aucune raison de laisser les
églises fermées
si les établissements scolaires et
quelques commerces peuvent reprendre
leurs activités
l'impatience commence à grandir beaucoup
de personnes la patience a été comme une
école c'est en même temps rappelé le
sens que pour les fidèles la célébration
eucharistique c'est pas simplement le
fait d'aller à la messe et sur
l'expérience qu'ont un dieu qui est
vivant et qui nous rassemble et que la
fois l ai pas vécu de manière
individuelle et une expérience
personnelle évidemment mêle aussi
communautaire et on peut pas séparer la
dimension de communauté et ben de
l'eucharistie
c'est un rendez vous que le christ nous
fixe l'église souhaite de nouveau
rassemblé un besoin pour vivre sa foi et
la nourrir car dans ces lieux force est
de constater que l'esprit de dieu touche
décidément tous les êtres vivants